عوده الى تحذيرات بولندا من الوضع على
الحدود الذي تصفه بالاكثر خطوره بعد تحرك
اكثر من مئه مسلح من قوات فاجنر نحو ممر
سوالكي لكن ما اهميه هذا الممر ممرس هو
ممر استراتيجي يبلغ طوله نحو 65 كيلو مترا
ويقع على الحدود بين بولندا
ويربط بين كلنينغراد وبلاروسيا ولطالما
مثل نقطه شائكه بالنسبه لموسكو يشكل هذا
الممر مصدر قلق لانه في حال سيطرت موسكو
عليه ستعزل دول البلطيق الثلاث وهي
ليتوانيا وبولندا وبلاروسيا عن بقيه
الناتو واوروبا بطبيعه الحال اشرنا الى ان
ممارسه والك يفصل بين اذا بلا روسيا
وكلينجراد الروسيه التي ترابط فيها القوات
واليات روسيا ضخمه وهذا ينقلنا الى معطى
جديد
نضيف الى اهميه الممر حيث تمثل منطقه
كالينينجراد الروسيه كما نشاهد الواقعه
وسط الاراضي الاوروبيه على سواحل بحر
البلطيق اهميه جيوسياسيه استراتيجيه بالغه
للسلطات في موسكو خصوصا في ظل الحرب على
اوكرانيا وتوسع النيترو اثر ذلك بطلب
فنلندا
والسويد الانضمام الى الحلف نجاه اخرى
يمكن بهذا الممر ان يكون فرصه نيتو
لمحاصره
وخلق التحركات العسكريه الروسيه في بحر
البلطيق ما يضعه في عمق تنافس يشتد مهددا
بالنشوب الصراع المسلح بين الجانبين
وبحسب خبراء فالافضليه العسكريه لروسيا في
ممرس والكيك يكمن ذلك في قدرتها على توفير
القوه الضروريه لاي عمل في هذا الممر
والحفاظ على خطوط امداد سليمه بل وتحريكها
ونشرها بشكل اكثر سلاسه
من الاكثر قلقا هولندا فهي قلقه من احتمال
امتداد حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا اليها
وبولندا هي عضو سابق في حلف وارسو كما انه
عضوا كامل في النيتو منذ عام
1999 ويقول رئيس الوزراء البولنديين
مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
اقتربت من مدينه غرودنا في بيلاروسيا
بالقرب من الحدود البولنديه وبدات بولندا
في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر نقل اكثر من الف
جندي الى شرقها وسط تصاعد المخاوف من ان
يؤدي وجود مقاتل فاينر في بيلاروسيا الى
زياده التوتر على طول حدودها في تلك
المنطقه وبحسب مسؤول في وزاره الداخليه
الليتوانيه تنظر بولندا في اماكن في امكان
اغلاق حدودهما مع بيلاروسيا اذا شكلت
مجموعه فاغنر الروسيه تهديدا لهما على كل
الاضاءه اكثر حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من اكسفورد الدكتور
فرانك ليدوي الخبير العسكري والضابط
السابق في المخابرات العسكريه البريطانيه
سيد فرانك مرحبا بك معنا اذا المخاوف
البولنديه هل لها ما يدعمها على الارض في
هذا الشريط الحدودي سوالكي
اسعدتم مساء
البولنديين يقلقون من شيئين اولهما
امكانيه ان مرتزقه قد يدخلون بولندا عن
طريق
الحدود وبالتالي يفكرون بغلق الحدود بين
بيلاروسيا وفولندا
هذا اعتقد هو قلق مشروع
وهناك امكانيه لتسلل يقوم بهؤلاء الافراد
وامكانيه ما يمكن نسميه
اعمال ارهابيه ولكن ليس هناك اي امكانيه
اطلاقا وهذا هو الخطر الثاني ان نقوم ان
يهدد
مرتزقه فاكنار
الرابط او المره السؤالكي ويسيطر عليه في
اي مرتزقه واي قوه عسكريه
حتى لو كانت مسلحه او مدرعه سيد ست دمر
على خلال ساعه واحده من قبل القوات الجويه
للنيتو
وهذا محاوله الدخول
ما هي المعطيات المتوفره الان على الارض
التي تستدعي كل هذا القلق البولندي
السؤال وجيه للغايه اعتقد ان هذا الامر هو
السياسي وليس عسكري او هو خطر سياسي وليس
خطر عسكري في الاسبوع الماضي الرئيس من
بيلاروسيا
اشارت بشكل عابر وان كان ذلك ليس بعذرا بل
كان مقصودا تماما بان الضيوفه من منظمه
قد يفكرون بالتدخل
في
مطارات تجهيز ومحطات القطارات التجهيز
الموجوده في
ويبدو ان بولندا ترد على ذلك ولذلك جهز ان
كيف ان السيارات العسكريه البولنديه بدات
التوجه الى الحدود وذلك
لتوفير نوع من الامن البولنديين وليس
لمواجهه اي خطر عسكري حقيقي الخطر الذي قد
يكون على يد مجموعات صغيره او افراد
ارهابيه وليس بهجوم عسكري ولكن اعين روسيا
ايضا تراقب هذا الممر الحيوي بالنسبه لها
جدا خاصه مع وجود كلينينغراد في هذه
المنطقه التي ترى بانها هي جيو استراتيجيه
وحيويه لها ولكن يحاول ان تعزلها وتطويقها
فيها هنا السيد فرانك برايك كيف ستكون
الخطوات الروسيه في ظل هذا التوتر
اوكي اذا روسيا
[موسيقى]
برايك الناتو فورا يتحرك في حال حدوث اي
خلل في هذه المنطقه هذا الممر
لو كان هناك اي تحركات عسكريه
روسيه في ذكر المنطقه فذلك سيؤدي الى
تفعيل
الماده الخامسه من اتفاقيه التي تقول
الهجوم على اي بلد في النيتو هجوم على
الكل وودناك احتمال اخر ان روسيا يمكن ان
تتبرع من اي هجوم يقوم به فاغنر ومرصقتها
على فيه هجوم على اي مطار او اي هدف اخر
هندسه التعامل معهم
روسيا فعلت ذلك سابقا في سوريا في الواقع